HAMILTON TRIES TOWILL TELL YOU T
--  ON THE BACK HAND.
0:15 SECONDS IT IS REQUIRED FOR
AND AHO.  BACK LAST
SEASON.
IT WILL THE PUCK. VERY PATIENT,,
AT A CHANCE
VALUABLE. IN REGULATION AND
GETS THE SHOOTOUT WINNER!
AND THEER.
LOOK AT THAT BEAUTIFUL ANGLE,
LOOK AT  LINE.
DROPS ITPOPS
AND THE BLUES WIN!
R, THAT IS
THERE.
ABLE TO GET IT ONAD,
WHO GAINED THE LINE AND TOOK IT
BACKHAT WILL BRING A FULL
CHANGE. TRAVIS ZAJAC
EXCEPT FOR MATHEW BARZAL.
STEPS IN. HE GOT
HE SCORES! ARM OF SHESTERKIN.
HE
ATTACK, HE BACKS OFF, WORKS IT
OVER, CROSS ICE, HAS A TRIGGER,
ABOUT THE
SWING SHOT MOVED TO BUILD SPEED
JOHANSEN JUST STABS AT HOME,
OVER THE PAST.
>> Willy: NOW HERE COMES THTHE
GO BACK THERE, TRIES TO GET HIM
A LITTLE BIT BUT KHUDOBIN WAS
IMPATIENT.
>> Willy: HERERE
DeBRINCAT.
ROSLOVIC COMES UP WITH IT.
ONE MAN BACK.3-
2. A GOOD PASS
THROUGH,
HAGEL AND THE HAWKS
GET A HUGE EXTRA
POINT.
A BEAUTIFUL THE ICE.
RILEY MAKES THE TO
DEBRUSK.
IT IS NOW CRAIG THE
GOAL.
TWO ON.
TOOK AWAY THE FIVE
HOLE.
THERE IS THE
RIGHT.
I DON'T THINK HE SHOT
IT WHERE HE WANTED
TO.
Jack:  ES HIM.
Jack: JAKE DEBRUSK
CAN END IT.
SPEEDING RIGHT DOWN
THE SLOT.
AND HE AT THE
FINISH TO
PANTHERS IMMEDIATELY SPREAD  OR
IT ONTO THE FLANK INTO THE ONE
WE GO.
AHEAD.
HEDMAN.  VICTOR.
SO MUCH STEAM.
MARKUP IS JUST TRYING TO PICK
THAT PASS OUT  OFF THE
JARED Mc
GOT THE PUCK, MAYBE A CHANCE.
THE OPENING 90 Y BACK.
NOW THE FOOT  RS
THE ZO THE REBOUND, LETANG.  TT
IT BACK TO THE TOP OF THE
CIRCLE
WHAT A MOVE AND A BUNCH OF
THEM.
IT IS STHE
SCORESJUST ENOUGH WITH THE
BACKEN